avec nous ses rivales à avocat au
barreau de paris spécialiste du
numérique bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin alors pourquoi ce
projet de loi de la loi via est-il ainsi
controversé il est très controversé
parce que bien évidemment tout le monde
s'accorde à dire qu'il faut lutter sur
les contres les messages haineux sur
internet maintenant le parti pris de
l'article 1er de la loi c'est lui qui
cristallise toutes les toutes les
remarques et les les critiques va donner
les clés du camion de la modération de
ses contenus aux gaffes à on va
galvaniser en fait les contenus
d'internet a donné à twitter à facebook
la possibilité de censurer et de sueur
censurer les contenus qui paraît très
hasardeuse illicites ou illégaux est
donc plutôt que de confier cette mission
un rouge juge judiciaire
on va préférer le donner aux gaffard et
7 sa peau d'un risque énorme sur la
liberté d'expression
alors est-ce qu'il ya quand même des
points positifs dans ce projet de loi il
y en a quelques uns notamment la
création d'un parc et d'un parc et
numérique
donc il ya une très bonne idée d'avoir
des gens spécialisés qu'ils puissent se
consacrer à 100% sur 7 sur cette tâche
le problème est comme d'habitude ça va
être quel moyen avec battent ils
disposaient il faut donner les moyens à
la justice c'est toujours le même
problème
si on veut que les contenus sur internet
soit davantage sanctionnés il faut
donner des moyens humains et matériels
aux magistrats et à la justice en
général et le parquet qui va être créée
devra également être dotée de moyens
suffisants pour pouvoir mener à bien sa
mission alors un la mesure la plus
polémique un qui a été réintroduite en
commission des lois
cette mesure elle prévoit que les
réseaux sociaux retirant donc en moins
de 24 heures les contenus haineux
signalés par les utilisateurs sous peine
d'une amende qui peut aller donc de
250000 euros à 20 millions d'euros en
cas de récidive
ce que ces sanctions elles sont
elle vous semble applicable alors en
allemagne on a une loi à peu près à peu
près identiques qui fonctionne depuis
maintenant pratiquement deux ans il ya
eu des amendes qui ont été qui ont été
qui ont sanctionné des facebook
notamment
alors c'est applicable bien évidemment
sauf que qu'est ce qui va se passer
quand il va y avoir les contenus
objectivement illicites sont
relativement maintenant retirer
facilement par parler parler les
plateformes
twitter est un petit peu à part mais ils
ont globalement il ya eu beaucoup
d'efforts de fait sur la modération
maintenant la grosse difficulté ça va
être les jeux qu'on appelle les contenus
grille est à dire des messages le
objectivement ne sera pas forcément bien
savoir si c'est illicite ou pas mais
commencer la modération généralement
c'est par des algorithmes c'est par une
intelligence artificielle
on va donc de paix fallait facebook et
twitter vont mettre une intelligence
artificielle qui va systématiquement
enlevé il y aura des mots clés de qui
est le mot-clé apparaîtra on enlèvera le
dès que s'est signalée et donc la
liberté d'expression pourra être mise à
mal avec avec 7
cet excès de zèle pour éviter justement
de payer les amendes et qu'elle est
l'institution qui va être en charge des
contrôles des sanctions le csa très
curieusement parce que le csa s'est
encore une fois on essaye de deux mètres
des pouvoirs de plus en plus important
au csa qui est normalement le gendarme
divertir le jeune homme de la télé la
radio et de la radio et là on
l'introduit de plus en plus sur internet
il y avait déjà eu des velléités et dans
d'autres des lois précédentes est là
donc on accroît sa sa puissance et sa
régulation
je ne suis pas persuadé que ça soit le
rôle du csa de pouvoir s'immiscer dans
le sur internet est contrôlé par exemple
les
les contenus de youtube et autres les
compétences justement pour pouvoir
réguler de manière efficace sur le web
le csa a bien évidemment un certain
nombre de compétences après on va le
doter de pouvoirs
ce qu'il va voir également les moyens de
le faire et est-ce que c'est au csa tout
simplement de pouvoir le faire je une
nouvelle fois je reste persuadé et mavia
attendait en est convaincu en rappelant
le rôle du juge sauf que le juge
judiciaire
aujourd'hui est bien mis à mal et qu'on
va on va le retirer alors que c'est lui
le juge naturel de ce qui est illicite
ou non sur internet donc là c'est la
justice qui doit trancher pour moi c'est
totalement est vrai tout à fait la
possibilité il ya la loi de 2004 et la
loi de 1881 ça fonctionne très bien il
ya des référés qui sont possibles le
juge doit normalement pouvoir faire son
travail
elle n'a pas besoin d'une nouvelle loi
pour pour ça il avait évoqué tout à
l'heure s'agissant de la liberté
d'expression quels sont les dangers de
ce projet de loi les dangers c'est que
pour éviter de payer les amendes chaque
fois qu'un internaute va signaler un
contenu dangereux ou à contenus
illicites et bien la plateforme va dire
bon je ne prends pas de risque je
supprime le message et puis on voit ce
qui se passe
donc c'est ça cette obligation de
résultat mais là à la charge de la de la
plateforme qui va normalement la
conduire assure modéré et donc est pour
ça que les sénateurs avaient introduit
ce qu'on appelle l'obligation de moyens
essayez de faire un un billet entre le
signalement et puis la modération
malheureusement la voix sénatoriales
mais le risque de ne pas de ne pas
l'emporter à la fin puisque c'est on le
sait très bien
c'est l'assemblée nationale qui gagne
enfin en fin de compte donc c'est toi et
wiam malheureusement je pense dans les
faits sera sera votée en l'état c'est à
mon avis une véritable un véritable
problème pour la liberté d'expression et
c'est une voix un peu liberticide quand
même merci ses rivales à pour cet
éclairage rappelle que vous êtes avocat
au barreau de paris spécialiste du
numérique merci à vous